In this problem, a municipality is
evaluating several stormwater treatment
trains to reduce total suspended solids
discharged to a nearby stream.
A stormwater runoff event contains 500
mg per liter of TSS.
Each treatment train consists of a
pretreatment device followed by a
primary treatment best management
practice.
The treatment factors or the fraction of
TSS removed for each process are
provided in the tables.
What is the overall removal efficiency
of a treatment train comprised of a
vegetated swale followed by a
constructed wetland?
So, this is another problem where the
reference manual does not have anything
to do with solving the problem.
Instead, it can be solved simply by just
following what the question is asking.
So, the most important part here is
recognizing that the successive
treatment technologies are not additive.
Rather, we need to know how much TSS is
removed by one
before inputting that into the next.
This is different than the last problem
that we posted because there we had two
factors that could simply be multiplied
together
to get the correct answer.
This current problem goes one step
further and makes you subtract the
percent removed from the total at each
step in the process.
However, since it's asking for the
answer as a percent, we can start from
100% instead of from the given 500 mg
per liter.
Let's solve this problem three different
ways to show what I mean.
Fast, medium, and slow.
Let's start with medium.
So, we are looking for the overall
efficiency
of a vegetated swale and a constructed
wetland.
So, we can see here that the vegetated
swale
removes 25% of TSS
in the first step.
And then the constructed wetland will
remove 65% of what remains.
So, for step one
we're going to say
100% or in this case
just the number one
minus
100%
*
0.25
which would be the 25% from the swale.
Obviously, that's going to equal
75% remaining.
So, that's the amount
remaining after pre-treatment.
In step two
we can now subtract
from that 0.75
65%
of that number.
So, 0.75 again *
0.65
given by the wetland.
And this is going to give us 0.2625
which will be
the amount remaining after both
pre-treatment and the BMP.
Make sure you don't accidentally select
that as the answer
since
we're looking for the removal efficiency
not the amount remaining.
So, the final step
would simply be
to subtract 26.25%
from 100%
to get
73.75%.
And that's really all it takes to solve
this problem.
So, that was the medium-speed way to
solve it.
If you were
having trouble thinking about it in
terms of percentages,
you still could do it the slower way,
which would be using the actual amount
of
TSS provided in the problem.
So, if we did that, it would be 500 *
100%
25%
to give us 375
mg/L.
And then 375
passing through the constructed wetland.
So, 1 - 0.65
and that would give us
131.25
mg/L.
And then
finally, we would have to
Finally, we would have to subtract from
that 135
and then divide by the total
and multiply by 100 to get
73.75%.
So, the first way might be a little
faster. And then finally, we have the
absolute fastest way. And this is if you
understand these types of problems
inherently
and are good at wrapping your head
around the math, which I'm not always.
So,
if you really wanted to,
you could say one
for the total amount of mass in the
problem
subtracted the first treatment
technology
and then multiply again by the second
treatment technology.
And you will see that this also works
out to 73.75%.
So again, all of these methods will get
you to the same answer.
They're all still pretty quick, but
I'm hoping this helps to further clarify
exactly what's going on in this type of
problem
as well as point out some ways that they
can be solved a little faster.
And that's it.